>>> BREAKI NEWS, WE ARE
CTONE ON
THE S OF HI  THEN HOUR
ILFOATIVE IT
JUST A SHORT TIMAGO,
GORNTO
THE DEAT ROPG  THAT
NUBLE.
ERE ARS ABOUT HOW WE PREPARED T
PIERCING SOUNTOES
AND "THE NEW YORTIAYTIVA
ACCORDING TO THERANTS RAY.
OF WHAT IT TOOK TO SURVIVE A
FIRE TT TRAVELLED ATNU.
-YD NOAH TUMKINSON AND  MILO, HE
EY WERN TRAFFIC.THEY THEY
THOUGHT WOULD SAVE T
ESCAPE TO THE OCEAN.
HEOME OF T M
RNNG
MI DIRTY. BROTHER,OU'RE GOIN
HOLY [ BLEEP ].
THANK YOU.MY PHONE WE'REOU OF .
E OKAY.
>> I JOINED NOBY 19-YEAR-OLD
NOAH TUMKINSON AND HIS DADAHYOUR
BROTHER, MILO.
HOW QUU
S ABT FIVE  OF THERE?
TO TINUTESE THE SMOKER
E R UP ON THAT BIG
>> WOW FAST?THAT F
OTERE WAS A LO
TRAFFIC.
WAS IT -- HOW CLOSE E FIRE
WHN YOUR
>> WHEN WEE
IT WAS STARTIN
SHOOT EMBERS DOWN ON GAND LIGHE
FIRE.
WE WERE LEAVING OUR IGH
>> SO, THE DECISION TO
THE OCEAN, WHE
THAT DECISION?
AND THE FIREEE BNEOMIN
ACROSS TT O LIGHT THE BUNG
ANYWHERE.-R WASN'T MOVING
THE TRAFFIC , NO ONE
WA
K HADO JUMP I
YO WHILE YOU WERE
HE WATTCHING SOME OF IT.ST WANLT
OFTALKWIE ON
SIDEOT THE LEFT AND
E STARTING TO DIE .
[ BLEEP ].
>> WHAT WAS THAT LIKE? SS HAPPE
ON SHORESMOKN,T SEEMS LIKE
IT'S STINGING YOUR
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS DIFFICULT
TO BREATHE.
CAN U  AUT
EXPERIENCE BEING IN THE WATE>>
AID  T
YOU O THE LEFT,
IF
MOMENT, I WA
>> HOW LONG GTO BE IN THE WATE
>> ABOUTR?
>>.
D  IN
THE R.
IT WAS ABOUT -FOME, I'
MOTHER ANTHEYE
>>OUE 19RDHEM TO
YOU SEEM TO KIND OF KNOW WT  DOM
COMING AND HURNGIS EYES.
>> CORRECT.
TOLD THEM BOTH NOT TOKIT WAS BEA
WAIRTIHE SMO
THAT
WERE STARTING TO LIGHT UP. THE
GENERAL.
I DIDN'T WANT -- I DIDN'T WANT D
A DIFFERUI, AN HIGHE IN
KNOWGET IN YOUR KIDS UNTIL THE
MORNING.AN, I CAN'T IMAGINE WHA
IKR YOU.
>> YEAH. WAS ABOUTW THAT THE FE
HAD GONEGH THEIR
T ALLORHOOD BY SOMETHATW ONLINN
I HAD ATTY
IDEA THAT THEIR HOUSE HAD  DOW.
AND I WAS JUST TERRI , YOU
WORST , THEY'RT ENOUGHHECOAT LED
GET INTO T OCEANNOA WHERE THEY
.FYING TO JUST
THINK ALE ENS I
WAS -- I KI HAD TO TLEGHD ST FE
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE WHO KNOWS
GET IN TOUCH WIT
>> SO, THEY SPENT,NOW,
ABOUT 12 HRSINHEN THEY HAD TO E
FROMTHEY FINALLY GOT
WHERE THEY WERABO GE
CELL PHO, GO UOPA
BUILDING, AND THER HIGH ENOUGH M
WAG TO MY HB
SAYING, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOON?
MY KIN'T HEARD  THEM.
WHILE I G THIS IG CLED MED FIRS
TO MISDAD, WE'RE OKAY.
THAT WAS SUCH A  IKNEW HE  B.,
THEY'RE SAFE.PENS,
GOOD.
LIFE'S GOOD AT THAT POIN.
UNDERSTAND EVEN
SHTE VEHICLE.YO IN DANGER.NK YO
DE THET
HAG OVER EVERYTHING. SMOKE WASUW
WE STILL HAD SK
AND WE MINUTE TO SIT.
AND, YOU KNO
CAR -- OTTERTHAN BEINGE.
BUT IT WASILL SO HEAVY.
STARTEDO FEEL
INA NEED RIGHT NOW, WHAT THE
FUTUREOO LIKE?>> YOU KNOW, IT'A.
SO, WE NEED THOSE DONATIONS
SPANNETHAT TIME.D OST PEOPLE - .
PEOPLE AREE TO G
VE  OTHER PEOPLE. WHO
USE BURNED DOWIN LAHAINA
AS W
OUR BUSINESSD DOWN.
BUT THE R OF T B
E BU HISIGHBORS.
EVERYTHING.
SO MANY PERE WIT HRIGHT NOW.
>> YOUT O PROUD OFOA.
YOUR SON, HA
I MEAN, TO BE AND --
>> INCRE>> -- INCREDL THOSE MOMS
OF.
HE MOMENHEAY I FELT SO
PROUD HE W A
ME ABOUT HOW THE WHOLED THAT HE
TEM
FOR HIS BROTHES MOTHER.
AND THEYD EA O TO
TR THEM TO HER ANWAS SO CALM I,
VERY,  C'S -- , VERYF
THYS.
>>OAH, IF I EVER I
YOU
U D HEADN  SHOULDE DOINGDAVID, H
THANK YOU SO MUCH.I WISH YOU CO.
>> ABSOLUTELY ANRS